okay let's talk about that stay trashy
tour baby sweet coming in full effect
yeah first leg of the tour has been
announced we went all over the country
gang it's a good good time come out and
see us yeah gang starting in March we're
going to be in Baltimore Virginia Beach
Richmond Oklahoma City Dallas Houston
Austin then in April baby we're hitting
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
then in may we got Tampa Dania Beach
Florida Raleigh North Carolina then in
June we're doing Cleveland and Columbus
get those tickies let's party gang see
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy yeah just a big old piece of
trash I'm your hostage Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
at antuti's basement she's upstairs
filing some serial numbers off some
power tools okay I don't know what she's
up there hi Jinx and Sue per use my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table he is the CEO of are you garbage
new starting quarterback and a Tampa Bay
Buccaneers yes give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan congratulations thank you
well I'm about to take everybody's money
in an FTX scam what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are
like I would like to say a prayer a
moment of silence for the greatest
website of all time better than Google
better than Yahoo better than as Jeeves
I'm talking
www.patreon.com are you garbage baby you
sign up over there you put your little
email in you create a little password
you get access to over 100 episodes of
eyg yep over 100 episodes of hard
feelings which is a show where we really
let it all hang out here we do uh we
have tons of footage on there we have
Road shows we got behind the scenes
Vlogs Cribs of our houses it cribs tours
of our house got everything on here golf
the Dave and Busters it's a good time
over there we got it all Sam yam and
Jack Hunt he's out shout out to them
patron saints baby shout out to the
homies shout out to the bozos and now
but a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works to ones and
twos crosses the t's dots the eyes give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes I'm I'm
jammed up at the crib I took a light out
of my bathroom and moved it into the
living room dude
wait A light bulb a light bulb I think
he had a lamp in your in your bathroom I
was like Jesus what he was spy who has
that
a light bulb that's tough if you got a
lamp in your bathroom it's red it's a
red light
damn dude then you have mice's pets
nothing worse than dim Lighting in the
bathroom that's real Shifty that's bad
you don't know what you're brushing oh
who are you that's not my hair
Kippy how the hell are you I'm good
buddy thanks for asking and thanks for
having me on this wonderful program me
I'm good myself thank you for asking
sure my nose is still sore still jammed
up yeah yeah that's good we're putting
that behind us trying to put that behind
us foot forward yeah uh-huh trying to
keep my weird trying to keep your weird
lesions to yourself pretty pretty sure
it's slowly working its way across the
table to me Jesus Christ oh man how bad
would you be hi Welcome to our new
segment are you a leper if I gave you a
ringworm or impetigo how mad would you
be don't even I I mean dude I left you
the other day and my nose was itching
the whole ride home I was just like man
this [__] guy gave me whatever he has
I know it nose cooties
I got a bone to pick with that sleep
apnea company it's ridiculous I didn't
know that you had to have water in there
what you don't have to have water in
there okay I'm not sure you know what's
going on with any of it to be honest
with you I mean that's what it seems
that you don't know no it's from my was
from my mask sure you would think you
would read the manual for your life
support system yeah ah let's wing it I
got these extra parts laying around I've
been using root beer this is crazy
anywho that's neither here nor there
yeah I apologize to the fans for my
extra grossness this week no stop it
thank you oh
um got the Valentine's Day coming up
Valentine's Day is coming up and me and
you are in a weird uh a first time
situation where we're going on separate
vacations wait that's weird we don't go
on vacations together we're going on
vacations at the same time yeah two
separate that's never happened where we
both have done that but that'd be weird
if we both were going on vacation to the
same place and I would ignore you for
sure I'd have to have my room change can
I change my table it would be like
forgetting [__] forgetting h-poly
uh
um yeah this art so this is my first uh
kind of adult vacation where uh-huh and
I I've realized where are you going
Hedonism The Ripping and the thing uh
I've realized as I prepare for this I
was supposed to go a couple of weeks ago
it had a shift around
uh going to Puerto Rico Puerto Rico I'm
not
uh my vacations have always been the
shore Jersey Shore that's it you take a
bathing suit maybe a pair of basketball
you do a European romp though yeah I
have
got weddings family [__] like that yeah
but that's typically like we're in
frankfur you know I you know for sure
this is the first time I'm doing it like
as just chilling just going on a
vacation that that's always like hey we
have to go here for oh you know her
friend's wedding her brother's wedding
you know something there's an obligation
yeah which is not I got an obligation
where I'm going not necessarily not how
I would I didn't enjoy myself but it's
like you had to be at a certain place at
a certain time doing a certain thing
sure thing I got a little bit of that
obviously you got fam out I got fam I
got the wedding all that kind of stuff
yeah you're also both going to places
that feel foreign but still use American
currency I know that's what I'm not I
don't know the whole passport thing I'm
bringing mine just in case just in case
I get jammed up at the border I pay my
goddamn tank the Border it's an island
idiot I'm bringing paper towels
straighten myself out uh yeah I've
realized I was like all right cool we
booked it and I was like oh I don't have
anything for a beach you got no Cabana
where I got no Cabana well bathing you
know the bathing suit I do but it's like
a shitty one that I last year's fashion
no it's a shitty one I bought at a hotel
to go into the hotel pool and I've never
washed that I think I put in a plastic
bag and left in my suitcase for about
two three months and now it's got black
mold on it are you trying to go uh like
official Caribbean you're gonna wear
like uh aguayevada and stuff like that
why Avera yeah you better clean it up
the Cuban shirt ah I don't think so no
that's a little too much huh down there
looking like Vin Diesel I realize I
don't have a nice bathing suit I don't
have flip-flops you got flip-flops I
don't do flip-flops anymore they make my
ankles swell up flip flop the loosest
shoe in the world I don't know what it
is man it's that [__] toe
they don't fit my feet right it's weird
huh but they're velcro you set them
exactly how you want I might get a new
pair of Crocs because the ones I have
are prescription that I got from my dad
I inherited them from my father
wait in this estate sale you're wearing
your dead dad's prescription Crocs yeah
they're my comfy shoes I don't have
spots I wear them in here slide them off
or if I'm going to try on pants because
it's a pain in the ass to get my shoes
back on sure about a lot of embarrass
myself with a DXL that's tough to do I
hear in front of the other beds at the
flat line for a couple of minutes
laughs
um okay but what's your gear uh your
your day-to-day gear ain't great so your
Beach wear can't be nice I'm coming to
the end of my gear cycle right now I
need to re-up on gear dude you needed a
re-up on gear about four years ago and
what you're supposed to do is you're
supposed to wait a little longer and
then make a move who says that it was
the fourth quarter you got to wait till
the first of the year what gather up my
how's your Beach how's your Cabana where
look because I went out I got I got two
new bathing suits Amazon Basics okay 11
bucks a clip nice I got black and dark
gray so I can pee in them and no one
knows sometimes the color Fades on them
and get real jammed up
you walk out in their purple or
something yikes
these colors don't run I can't get
caught peeing in the pool I don't got
jack [__] man
I gotta do all that stuff huh yeah I got
I got plenty of socks and fresh
underwear that's all I got that's I mean
that's that's standard you're an adult
I'm good I got on these I'm gonna pick
up uh you gotta pick up you gotta pick
up your own for like two weeks I'm gonna
have two tree pair of trunks you can't
be the same guy wearing putting on a wet
bathing suit I'm gonna do a little
shopping when I get over there
because they favor the big boys over
there crash of all trash moves shopping
on vacation shopping to wear this stuff
shopping on vacations rich guy stuff oh
we're gonna go I'm going straight from
the airport to a Walmart yeah you're not
going to Cartier or whatever that's not
hitting the Gucci store just you're not
calling them down and shutting down
Versace no I'm gonna I'm gonna hit a
Walmart I'm gonna get a couple bathing
suits I gotta go to the Big and Tall
store over there I gotta get a nice
Hawaiian for the wedding let's try to do
that here I mean a Hawaiian I'll give
you do that there but like not at a
wedding
Hawaiian shirt at a wedding it is it's
Hawaii it's not Cleveland
I'll give it to him that's the one time
you do wear Hawaiian that's right that's
where that's where you Flats [__] get
a nice [__] Hawaiian with a nice pair
of slacks and a nice pair of summer
shoes and my dad's Crocs
I'll get a little collar before the
wedding may pull a little jewelry on get
a you know let me see my jewelry put the
watch on slick the hair back trim up the
beard a little bit sure but don't go
shopping for like normal clothes out
there that's a tough look you're a
little better than that come on you're
not I'm trying to get you better than
that I mean dude you can't go to Hawaii
and hit a Walmart why not that's just
something you do here now I'm sick
everything here I like something
different over there it's a Walmart but
it's more summery
it's summer over there I don't want to
buy summer clothes in the winter here
when I can buy summer clothes in the
summer there does that make sense I I
think it's you just trying to get out of
doing stuff as I think there's an
element of convenience yeah okay plus
I've hit the ceiling but like uh
I would be I've hit the ceiling on the
sizes on my target pants
sure and I don't know what DXL I gotta
go to dxo tomorrow get some gear yeah do
that see what they got I I think it's a
bad look if you roll up to all your
in-laws hey how you doing I gotta go buy
underwear I'll be right back I didn't
bring a luggage wearing a robe yeah and
I'll do that show up prepared to go
that's the adult thing I'll have clothes
on you just said he had underwear and
socks I have a couple pairs of pants
I'll be all right
don't do shopping but bathing suits I
gotta get a nice bathing suit you gotta
get a couple you're over there for a
long time you're a man of you're a man
of stature now I'm gonna do a couple of
nice button-down Hawaiians okay you know
where to the beach I don't know how much
Beach Frolic and I'm gonna do why
there's Hawaii because Hawaii doesn't
want to go on the beach man you are a
different kind of weird
I swear to God
I don't get you if I get some color real
quick I'll let it hang out plus I'm over
the belly now
what do you mean I'm over the belly
bathing suit now I go over to belly now
you tuck in tuck it in Tuck the flaps in
like a big dress shirt that thing goes
in
[Laughter]
looking like a hockey goalie hey they
connected to my socks uh okay all right
I need a 52 waist with a five inch
inseam
Jesus I gotta pick up some fresh gear do
a little shopping cool yeah
yeah I'm gonna get it nice okay good you
got anything uh romantic planned it's
gonna be uh Valentine's Day no I'll be
on a plane so I get away with it
pretend like I'm sleeping
both through Valentine's Day babe sorry
I got drunk on ipas see you on
President's Day honey uh we'll actually
be here for Valentine's Day I got
nothing planned but the birds big on
like doesn't have to be something we got
the day before the day after sure I
think last year we did like a day or two
before because our my anniversary [__]
what day is it yikes my anniversary is
somewhere really before about yeah
congratulations thank you it's nice what
are you gonna get her
buddy I just realized it was Ariana it's
man you really just fall into like the
stereotypical old guy as you get married
see with free sponsor stuff we got
liquid IV she loves I hear well said you
were dehydrated what an all-time jam up
you're just trying to pull on Kimmy he
just remembered and then you try to get
him to publicly admit what he's gonna
get lock him down trip to [__] Puerto
Rico how about that that's what I say
yeah I'm going to Puerto Rico for that I
heard you're getting her a diamond
necklace that's what I heard no that's
not you got the wrong newsletter you
don't like jewelry and everything I pick
out she returns I'm an idiot I mean a
Mercedes-Benz
that's a nice gift it's a good thing
she's not a fan of the program
did your mom get you Valentine's Day
stuff when you were a kid
no no I mean like I always did I mean
like the candies maybe but they were
like to take him to school and you would
do like uh you know you would fill out
the little cards like whatever whatever
I had a little I had a little setup when
I would get home yeah yeah she gave me
the conversation on her panties and [__]
what are you talking
a little freak Show
um there wasn't sexual she didn't give
me a dildo or nothing
ma pretty please Gonna Save Me a lot of
time find out what's up
um at what age are we talking here I
mean I still get a card from her a
Valentine's Day card maybe a scratcher
in it I got a Valentine's Day card I
gotta I gotta uh St Patty's Day card
okay you don't get any of that stuff no
I come home from school nah baby gets
blackout drunk and late
I [__] chicks dude I've eaten sweet tart
Hearts yeah shout out to them by the way
love a good sweetie yeah I mean that
stuff you would get like Valentine's Day
candy and I guess if I was like young
would be like you know yeah whatever it
would have more of a meat but like
no as an adult I don't get Valentine's
Day cards for my mom hmm
all right you Toby what dude no okay my
parents don't don't send me mail through
the U.S government for novelty holidays
yeah my mom just asked my address like a
week ago no [__] and I've been living
there for about a decade I get all that
stuff
yeah it's good I don't get candy anymore
I just find it on your own it looks like
I don't think you're dry bud I know
where CVS is yeah all right figure it
out yeah she used to always hook it up
all right we used to always do that
what's used to what age are we talking
here like into high school that's like
yeah incestual I would say maybe it's
your [__] and your mom's giving you
Valentine's Day cards that's weird she's
not sending me nudies or anything like
that I don't think it's that far away
it's just you know a couple scratch offs
[__] some candy like I said the
conversation Hearts yeah Sealed With a
Kiss sealed with a red lipstick
card smells like a French horn a little
squirter perfume
rub some deodorant on it yeah it's a
little weird I I would love to I'd love
to hear from the uh I mean maybe I'm
wrong on this I don't know I I you know
I think it's nice I mean we're two for
I'm not uh I always thought Valentine's
Day was more for kids anyway you just
say times day Valentine's okay
Valentine's Day okay Valentine's Day
maybe it is Valentine's it's not that I
know I know it's not maybe I think I did
say Valentine's Day when I was a kid
because it was Valentines
yeah the time of the Valen
I think we can all agree that of the
candy-based holidays Easter Halloween
Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
absolutely I disagree wrong man you're
wrong you're dead [__] wrong you ever
have one of those Dove Hearts those
little bangers yeah but that's like one
thing you get like that one I haven't
even begun you got the conversation
Hearts chalk you got their decent but
you can only do I a handful or two
otherwise
all [__] dried out it's like taking
perks
oh [__] for a week after that thing
um you got the lollipops you got I did
Lollipop you get lollipops they're heart
shaped though it's you're stretching
it's the same flavor what about those
little cinnamon Johns those things will
light you up I mean clear your sinuses
out yeah I don't Sudafed it's the worst
candy holiday I mean what are we talking
about
[Music]
you also have to realize when people
talk to candy or food about you you
can't you're emotionally have your heels
dug in and you don't all right you know
it's like because you love all candy I
think I have my research done is what it
is sure but it's full Valentine's Day
candy is good
this is what I'm saying you you
inherently somebody goes hey this is
better than that you take that that's
bad no one's saying it's bad it's just
not the best candy holiday it goes
Halloween
obviously yeah what the [__] are we
[__] [__] here then Easter
correct and then Valentine's Day and
then Valentine's Day exactly the
statement and then Christmas candy box
you get sugar on the brain and St
Patrick's Day candy
let's say root beer barrels what's St
Patrick's Day candy a slap for my
grandpa what are you talking about news
flash Jameson and Candy it is in my
family they do have those you ever
accidentally eat one of those when you
were a kid with a little liquor in them
or something man
the first time I had Bailey's was one of
those first time I made out with my
cousin
sorry Bill I'm all jacked up on snaps uh
yeah right let's quit screwing around I
hope you have a good time though you too
thank you I appreciate it man I hope uh
you know you hit as many Walmarts as
possible thank you in the most beautiful
place in the world and you go to a
[__] Walmart they got good
Superstores over there it's all right
this is the same stores yeah but there's
palm trees man spread out a little bit
different kind of dumb okay what do you
think about Helix baby oh slept in one
last night masturbated and won today
there you go not only an endorser the
kid's also a goddamn client over there
there he is Gang do yourself a favor get
over there to Helix sleep fill out the
questionnaire do a little quiz there
takes two tree minutes don't even start
with me I don't like it when I cut them
off it takes two three minutes they find
out what kind of sleeper you are they
match up they got 14 different styles
including luxury sure I need broads out
there have been nailed on a luxury
mattress I know I haven't do yourself a
favor pick one up yeah it's fantastic
I'll be real busy this season it's
fantastic as you know I've settled for a
long time to good folks over there he
looks were nice enough to send me in a
bird a mattress we took the two minute
sleep quiz I got I got linked up with
the sexy model
hahaha
can't wear a pair on these for me not
kid I got the Twilight model uh the
personalized matches straight to your
door free of charge best night sleep in
my life Helix is offering up to 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
garbage this is their best offer yet and
it won't last long get on while the
getting's good with Helix better sleep
starts now do it do it Kevin let's talk
about that pretty litter baby uh-huh oh
I tell you what when I brought that into
the house yeah man the bird was going
nuts she's like oh my God pretty litter
it's all the buzz around town they say
I'm not in a cat world but as a cat man
yourself apparently all the cat owners
are raving about it it's got this
special stuff in it when the when the
cat goes on it if there's something up
it could help detect it early they sent
me some turns out I got herpes
trying to get you from stop [__] in
the kitchen yeah right no but like
urinary tract infection stuff like that
any issues it turns a different color so
you know to get her down to the vet and
make sure the little Angel's okay yeah
so if you got a cat out there normally I
would just throw her out at that point
oh geez all right pretty literature
super light Crystal base also minimizes
mess and dust plus the crystals last up
to a month which means less scooping and
fewer trips than a garbage cane
leadership's free to your door in a
small lightweight bag uh you never run
out if you don't have a container kitty
litter uh taking up space and stinking
up the place as well here we go here's
the turkey
or the [__] catnip as I call it uh
pretty litter helps keep your cat
healthy and odors down you and your cat
are going to love pretty litter as much
as we do go to prettylitter.com garbage
save 20 on your first order there you go
that's pretty little.com slash garbage
to save 20 pretty litter.com garbage do
it now back to the show Gang
uh guys it is a gosh darn Family episode
as you know when you sign up for the
patreon we will answer your question on
the air which is the best way to do it
uh patreon the homies get the first
crack at it all right let's see this
one's from hold my balls
oh that was all right all right guys
anybody just didn't even put space in
between the words just hold my balls ten
dollar homie never had one red is it
garbage
as an adult to buy something that cost
over ten dollars with change I once
bought a case of beer with 145 dime geez
times
they're tough to count because they get
lost in your fingers say the case a case
of beer that was a 14.50 145 dimes would
be 14. a case of beer for 14 bucks 12
pack or uh 24 pack of like shitty uh
shitty cans yeah yeah I think back when
I was banging a 24 pack was probably of
like real [__] beer
11 bucks probably something like that
yeah 30 rack of PBR of 13.99 you do the
cold ones and you go if you go to the
beer store do you go in it you go into
the fridge and get a cold one yeah yeah
yeah it charge you a little more it
would always be like a dollar fifty more
for like a thirty right but I'll tell
you what it's worth the smell in there
I'm going in there with my dad I thought
I was [__] doing cold plunges yeah
yeah it's all right you talking you got
a bathing suit on a little sunburn
you're a little damp I think I got into
that cooler I think I got stuck in one
as an adult
the [__] you know how they have the
press release or whatever to get out get
dad trying to lock you in get away from
you no I wasn't I was buying my own beer
thank you very much and it just like got
jammed and I didn't panic because there
was a bunch of people in the store but I
was like and I was like old enough to it
was also one of those ones where I like
I think you could open the cooler door
and I could have like grabbed you you
know what I mean like you could like uh
reach through but uh I didn't panic I
like kind of I was like it was about
what do you mean like the glass one yeah
like you can open the glass door in like
a case
I'm freaking out I was supposed to go to
a party they're gonna be asking for me I
got all the beer I'm underage
oh
like the one in Baltimore how did you
know the gentleman was underage well he
was crying in the cooler asking for his
bumsy because he couldn't get his big
head out of the door for his wooby
yeah um
but I didn't panic because I remember it
was like it was one of those things
where I was like oh [__] I should panic
but then I was like no you're good and
then like you know Panic 10 seconds
later someone over or maybe like three
seconds later so yeah always panic I
didn't tell him again
hey it's all the way in the back
turn the lights out on them hey it's
every man for himself in the cold room
pal Man hitting the lights on somebody
as a kid that was [__] I never that's
not my kind of that's not my cup of
humor it's just a dick move man I'm
taking a deuce and now all of a sudden
it's in the I'm in the dark feeling
around a public restroom I'll fight you
for that without wiping the one thing we
didn't do with the Foley house was
messing around in the shower
is different
some of these rose petals in here I'm
getting what do you mean mess around in
the shower anything with the shot
because you slip and crack your head
open because I remember one time uh how
we learned this lesson is my dad was in
there taking a hot one and me and my
brother thought it'd be funny if we
snuck in and threw the cold water over
there
I would have got you he tuned up in my
house dude he came through that shower
curtain like Coke bear
I'm looking for blood
dude [__] right dude ripped it right
off [__] chasing this [__] yeah
that's a dick move I never liked that I
never liked uh I didn't play around with
that and Bloody Mary will get you if
it's the wrong [__] nope yeah if it's
the wrong combo goes down get them on
senior over there get the [__] out of
here did you have the the safety like
grip mat in your in Your Shower
[Applause]
yeah that and my semen was in there
called it a kitty soup we had that and
then we moved from that to uh we had we
had more of like traction on I think in
like the 90s it was like it's kind of
like sand like grip tape yeah that would
scrape your ball sack if you were taking
a tubby
dude I was grinding off my little Peach
I was like sliding on astro turf that
[__] would rip a knee oh yeah man [__]
that huh yeah yeah we had those things
you pull those things up after a little
while look at the bottom of that I think
when we had one of my dad I think my
stepmom implemented them and I think it
was like you had to take it off every
single time and like hang it over the
BET like hang it over the wall sure but
I didn't like it I had a friend in high
school that when you showered at his
house they had like they had just gotten
their bathroom redone and you had to
squeegee the inside of the Europeans do
that really yeah I oh no hold on I think
everybody does that that's what
squeegees are for in this I'm just
finding this out because some hotels
wait a couple months and spray a little
Tyler some hotels we stay and have it if
you ever noticed there's a squeegee you
gotta clean your own [__] thing no
but it's just for like the I don't know
what it's for we had a we had a glass
shower at a apartment that I stayed at
with my wife and we she bought us I'm
like who the [__] does that that's like
once every two months you spray with
some [__] lights all 100 this you
know the scrubbling bubbles do the work
for you yeah so you don't have to yeah
you just have to [__] dip and if you
didn't you got screamed up by his mom I
was taking a shower at last yeah [__]
out of here my mom be here in five
minutes [__]
and I didn't flush either you want that
smoke uh I remember growing on my buddy
had he got a big addition put on a house
big Edition contractor cash you know had
a bathroom with a urinal in it
and a steam room shower that's pretty
good yeah snap I'm talking my little
root in there nice to have an addition
yeah that's a spot wouldn't mind it
um let's see here this one's from dock
it burns uh is it garbage if you pay for
stuff out of the bank envelope from
cashing your paycheck all week that was
a good oh the Kippy did that for about
eight years I used to think that if you
kept that you would spend less money
yeah but then you don't because you're
you're not counting you're just digging
pulling out dubs the whole time with
your fingers like this to get in there
and getting that envelope [__] Friday
you couldn't tell me nothing dude I used
to whip around on my [__] Chevy Loom
that had the paint falling off with my
uh envelope and my glove box in my like
little center console who's the bank in
Philly am I thinking of Commerce
Commerce citizens it was a specific one
I can't remember that I always remember
when I was a kid
Fidelity uh maybe yeah like like
portilles First Union nah what's the
first Union
I don't know the Marco and Sons the
Bruno Brothers
yeah that was big that's a real big
Dirtbag thing that when I read that
question I was like holy [__] I did that
all growing up oh yeah poor states that
was big back and of course States Bank
um yeah dude that was a savings account
oh that might as well yeah that might as
well not have access to it I without
fail
every time even into my 30s I spent my
paycheck
that Friday night that week 100 100 I've
always said every time I worried about
it that every time
uh yeah you're gonna save this you're
going to start saving you're gonna
you're gonna do five bucks a day you're
gonna do that you gotta and every time I
would blow all of my [__] money on
the weekend and then somehow I would
make it work at the end of the month to
a degree well that was a thing I would
always tell myself if you could spend
the first week like you always live the
second week with no I would spend all if
I got paid every two weeks I'd spend all
my money the first week
and then I have to live poor the second
week I was going if I could live poor
the first week like I do the second week
I would have money to roll over into my
next paycheck man that's real Dirtbag
mentality but there was always the thing
too of like but nothing ever happened
I'm still here I got through it it never
[__] I mean we got pretty lucky sure
we'd be in a lot of debt right now sure
couple of bailouts sure you know borrow
a little cash off the brother your way
you're wearing your dead dad's Crocs at
the moment it's not like we're killing
it and you are too big to fail
and Steve Carell on the phone
but it's funny when you look at it like
that you know what I mean you panic
you're worried about it like hey man we
were very poor in debt with bad income
drinking problems
it's not I mean like on paper
you're jammed you're upside down I'm
upside down in a pack of Bernie's but
I'll tell you what get done working on
Friday
cash that check you get that [__]
bank envelope
I used to remember being like Skye was
the limit if I had if Friday around five
six o'clock you got your whole life in
front you can't tell me [__] the whole
weekend a pack of Bernie's doesn't even
register into the fresh pack just
[__] take that off the top that's for
you fresh pack yeah what you need is a
good network of like-minded scumbags oh
yeah you gotta know a bartender
somewhere something yeah you go there
we'll buy five drinks but we'll get ten
or whatever type thing I had a couple of
free shots I had a buddy we were on
opposite schedules every two weeks he
was on the one week I was on the other
so that was like beers on him the week
that weekend I got him the next weekend
so you were married
that's a two income household right
there floating Healthcare oh [__] it's
all right I remember we were back from
college it's me and Pat were my mom want
to give me money because you knew we
were just gonna go drink with it sure so
I'm like hey give us like [__] I'm
like just give me like 50 bucks like
let's go [__] she's like there's you
know beer here whatever we're like I
don't even want to go [__] you know
have some Pub Wings you know take a shot
at some [__] bar fly you know
make it or make a run at a deuce Hey
Arnold
all right
you know Valentine's Day is coming up
have you ever heard of Adam and Eve
so then we didn't have any money between
us and then Pat's like Grandmom called
and was like ah Pat I missed you but I
left 50 bucks at the house for something
like that he hung up the phone my
grandmom left me 50 bucks let's go to
the bar it's like let's [__] I'll
drive let's do it ah good question ah
um all right this one's from Brandon 20
board member let's go is it garbage use
a gum wrapper as a fake Grill Like
Rappers do that's a good time do you
ever do that as a kid team under the
eighth grade yeah it hurt my teeth oh
you can feel it it makes your teeth run
cold yeah no no I didn't like it nothing
gets me more than uh tinfoil chewing on
I can feel it yeah catching a cavity
that'll hit a different [__] planet
that's chewing on tin foil man you catch
a catch a [__] Hershey bar or
something like that you don't peel it
all off
bite down I'm quick are you eating
Hershey bars dude come on I get after
them
realize you're halfway down to your
elbow
you know what's you know what's pretty
top shelf speaking of candy that Hershey
almond bar I love how you bring up candy
speaking as you guys were just casually
talking about candy
or Valentine's Day
which is good candy
uh that's how you know it's fresh what
Halloween it's only one day a year it's
got to be fresh what Halloween
Valentine's Day holiday candy like that
you know it's fresh because they only
when they what do you think they're
making the day before man I've worked at
a candy company that year it's made that
year yeah that's fresh candy I've been
getting all that by wraps in this in the
warehouse since three three holidays ago
turn those pumpkins into Hearts so what
do you think they don't sell it on
January on the 15th they do what
they just clown yeah that's what they do
like produce you think they keep the
produce they keep it for the next yeah
some discount company will buy that and
hold it till the next year
well I only brush candy I only buy bread
I buy retail I'm not going to the I'm
not you're not going to the docks for me
you may you might who knows get a carrot
get a cargo cargo yeah bring it in from
Easter Island
just came in from Valentine's Day land
um uh what was that question
hit me what was it how long was it was
the one we just answered wait wait I
want to catch on a plane I want to get
it I want to get it uh it was the after
the envelope it was after the envelope
oh tin foil on the grill there it is we
used to too that was an orange slice I
remembered I just wanted to make sure
you guys sure I was an orange slice man
put stick down up there of course that
was good um you know what else was big
about that that didn't play well with
the ladies the tin foil from like gum
you could separate it remember like
Wintergreen or winter fresh yeah or like
juicy fruit that tin they would come on
the sticks uh-huh that had like the tin
foil wax paper on the inside then tin
foil on the outside you could separate
that tin foil off the wax paper I don't
remember that I'm telling oh yeah I'm
just I'm telling you you could you could
pull it apart and it had an adhesive on
the back of the tin foil like a really
light tin foil huh like kind of like
gold plated like gold crusted you know
whatever you know whatever like gold
gold leaf it would be called really yeah
and you could like put it on like a
Trapper Keeper or like you know whatever
yeah yeah and it would stick that's a
gum would you have to go through a lot
I'd buy a wholesale but that's a lot of
gum I do remember when gum was classy
when it did come in with the with the
paper and had the sleeve on it it was a
paper yeah then I think they realized
yeah this is you know we got two
different suppliers three different
manufacturers yeah it's always cut out
the middle man but that was classy there
used to be a quarter then they bumped
them up to 35 cents remember that that
winner that winter fresh I remember
complaining at a krauser so I yelled I
was like what the [__] is this lady hit
me over the head I only got a quarter on
me girl also used to sell cigars because
we were 14 and that was the law I was
like all right toots I got five boxes of
[__] marble or uh Black and Mild and
you're some kind of Dirtbag if you're
bitching about the price
what you kidding me
Jesus I needed it my mom's gonna know I
was smoking Black and Milds at 14.
man I remember one time wait with the
little yeah we would smoke Philly blunts
too dude let's sell us anything she goes
That's the Law I don't agree you would
just smoke them smoke them yeah like a
cigar yeah a big round of golf huh it's
our clothes to big deal
not good man we were 13 14 years old
and because they she wouldn't sell us
Bernie so you couldn't always get your
hands on Bernie's and some Adventure you
know adventurous kids we were looking to
smoke something
gonna get my hands on any sticky either
I had to do something to take the edge
off and this place krausers uh
Chrysler's crowd it changed names a
couple about 50 times but to experts it
was just old it was this old woman and I
was like I'm just gonna see if she'll
buy me if I'll be able to buy cigs and
she said no I can I was like oh all
right pack of Marlboro mediums and a
Wall Street Journal this place didn't
have the Wall Street Journal they did
have old Valentine's Day candy if you
needed I'll shake her off with these
romance novels but I kind of yeah I
remember walking in these Lean Cuisine
meals
a pack of condoms
for kids
this child support's killing me
how much would this come
so let's see you got Sour Patch straws
here you got uh pack of Kents how about
you get the [__] out of here and lock
your bike up next time
you [__] it's over between us
but she I tried to buy cigs and she I
was like yo pack of Marlboro Reds or
probably Newports at that time we were
banging let me get a pack of Newports
and she goes no I can't sell them to you
I know you're not 18. I was like all
right she goes but
are you 14 I go of course I'm 14 and she
goes I can sell you cigars that's the
law that can't be the law not no it was
never the law yeah it was 18. we card
the ID thing the whole thing for all
tobacco all tobacco products that's like
Civil War [__] oh yeah man yeah I was
like you know can you make your mark all
right you'll sign up for the you know
sign up for the draft but I don't think
she knew
I don't I think she just had bad
information she must have been like she
could have been on crack too I don't
know what their meth or something sure I
don't know what she was doing
um
but so we we went in every vetting
process everybody browsers everybody
it was me flip Pat Vinnie with the skin
it'll hold the whole crew of us and we
all got like [__] two packs of cigars
like cheap like Philly blunts or Dutch
Masters
I'm just hang up Swisher Sweets oh
Swisher sweet sort of the little bangers
and inhale
probably half and half you know I don't
know we didn't know what we were doing
just trying to get lifted and we dude we
bought about 20 packs of [__] cigars
and we all smoked like one who's having
a baby and
[Applause]
then and then flip called his mommy like
hey can you come pick us up and now
we're like we're like strapped to the
gills with [__] cigars and all smell
like the world's worst abstracted five
kids got in her car that all had just
smoked cigars and she's [__]
racetrack
she was like am I not supposed to say
something
how long have you guys been involved in
underground boxing that's what I want to
know
I still had one unlit my mouth is
chewing on it my grandfather chewed
cigars yeah didn't smoke him she would
get the nicotine but then I think that's
how you like lose your jaw and stuff
I ain't doing that no way that's [__]
Babe Ruth [__] that's Bernie's for me
folks do you hear that kids uh this
one's from our boy tanello out there
shut up
and Mrs T shout out to the
tonello's is it garbage pronounced Hulk
Hogan as Hulk Hogan because I do that
I've realized say it is it garbage to
pronounce Hulk Hogan as whole kogan
Hulk Hogan Hulk Hogan like it's h-u-l
kogan like his last name's kogan yeah
I'm a Hulk Hogan man a what Hulk Hogan a
double KH am I Hulk Hogan
Hulk Hogan Hulk Hogan it's Hulk it's all
it is like hallway Hulk Hogan's [__]
Hulk Hogan that's how it is kogan Jesus
and then Here Comes Hulk Hogan the
Mighty Duck from the rafters leg drop
Hulk Hogan it's all Hulk Hogan man I
missed the hulkster that was really
something else did something just happen
with him
no he joined Scientology I thought and
then I just I saw something that he
heard that he can't he lost feeling in
his legs jeez I don't know if that's
related to Scientology no why would it
be
Hulk Hogan is doing well and is not
paralyzed following back surgery there
you go they Nick something in him is he
a Scientologist
get roots on that I think he might be
and Stone Cold Steve Austin now
celebrates Kwanzaa is that true
shout out to Stone Cold Stone Cold be a
great guest by the way love to have him
dude okay if I could drink a beer it was
[__] with Steve Austin it's
unconfirmed but Hulk Hogan was spotted
with Tom Cruise tell me that's not the
most fun hang of all time wow that's a
good time right there I wouldn't want to
be there what no that's a lot of crazy
two pillars in their industry dangerous
Greece Mr kogan
you mean Tom Cruise damn the hulkster
and Tom Cruise oh dude get them in a
[__] movie oh yeah Top Gun three
let's go whoa just him [__] elbow and
[__] big Fighters no he's a leg drop
true there's a leg drop Man Macho Man
Randy Savage was the Flying elbow that's
true Mr kogan was a leg drop man
shout out to it did you get caught up in
the whole uh yeah his daughter's face oh
Brooke yeah I used to tug my little
route to her reality TV show what was it
called meet the Hogans I know Kevin
spanking it hour that's what I remember
that stay out of my room
where's my lotion you did huh oh did I
spank it to that I don't know if I did
that but yeah I mean probably that's
right because we have those 10-year
differences who were your little pre
little preteen crushes like that
Brittany was huge sure she was the
hottest of the hot was Britney can you
say you ever pulled your little route to
Brittany yeah publicly yeah a week ago
Dude I used to recall do you remember
the Box how I've had to talk about this
you did yeah the box and you would
request a video so you could tug your
route to said video oh really yeah I
didn't know that yeah so like Clint
biscuit would be on and then you know
Hit Me Baby One More Time would slide in
and Kippy be [__] snug as a bug in a
rug yeah two minutes and 15 seconds oh
yeah get it out I could do it two three
times back then
um so yeah her then Christina Aguilera
dropped the show she was the
edgier that dirty video I don't know you
were older that'd be creepy if you were
watching that nah I didn't get into it I
wasn't remember that dirty video she
shows her panties
like she like she's in a short skirt she
drops down you want to get dirty
I was probably only 25 or 26 when that
when all that Britney stuff dropped but
I still looked at his weird yeah because
the high school Catholic uniform yeah it
didn't seem right
um Elizabeth Hurley fan
shout out to it yeah but that was her
that was it was that that's when all
that [__] was hot like that bubble gum
pop [__] really blew up uh Beyonce when
she was still when it was still
Destiny's Child Elizabeth that [__] was
all big Shakira Shakira Elizabeth
Shannon Shannon what's her name Shannon
Elizabeth oh yeah the American Pie broad
yeah I don't care who you were she was
I got Dad's caught up too yeah yikes
peeking at that uh uh yeah well that was
a little [__] not hey Matt someone
call Adam or Eve something who's got a
swisher on him I think the edge off we
crack a window
let the air out uh all right let's see
here
um this one's from uh AOC is it garbage
to go to an Orioles game with your
friend and his dad and your friends up
your friend ends up being the DD back
home in this case you and your friend
are 12 years old and you live an hour
from the ballpark wait what the DD
designated driver so a dad took his son
and his son's friend to an Orioles game
the dag gets [__] housed and has to have
a 12 year old drive home holy [__]
that's wild there's no way that's I mean
that's 12 that's early 90s oh yeah
that's late 80s early night yeah and if
probably back then if you got pulled
over like officer he's
I'm too drunk to drive and they would be
like ah it's a good decision a 12 year
old he might have been Italian so he
could have a mustache
he drinks to Dad's his kid hey your son
there had a little drink sleeping in the
back
damn dude I remember my buddy's Dad one
time
had not a problem but he would he would
fall asleep driving Jesus that's such a
problem that's a problem no he wouldn't
do it
but it would be
he would he would get he would get real
tired when he was driving so instead
still a problem snow and so instead of
falling asleep at the wheel he would
just randomly if we were on like a
two-hour drive after like a half an hour
or 45 minutes if it was at night he
would pull over and just [__] sleep
for like a half an hour and we would
just be sitting here shaking and stuff
as a contractor he would pull off and
just park for like a half an hour and we
would just [__] sit there goofing
around that ain't safe and I remember I
went with him somewhere on a school
night I can't remember what it was
but he did that and I got home at like
11 o'clock my mom was like what the [__]
yeah and I'm like he pulled over and was
sleeping what the [__] was that probably
on oxy's nodding off
hey
I had a friend who you know used to
dabble in the opiates it was a huge
epidemic and I'm not celebrating the
fact by any means uh it was real shitty
uh no oh yeah but no it wasn't but he
would all my buddy would nod off he'd be
sitting at the bar with him you know hey
let's meet up let's go get a drink it's
just you and him sitting at the bar he's
[__] snoozefest like holding the
yinger and he's like hey man hey yeah
those Eagles are doing he would always
hop back into a sentence to make it look
like he wasn't sleeping
you know
tough tough tough drugs are bad folks
stay off them yeah listen to me
um
it can't be approved there you go uh
let's see here this one's from higgy pop
is it trashy to leave your cold
leftovers from the night before on the
dashboard of your car to have them
warmed up by lunchtime in the hot summer
months
I don't know if I hate this I gotta be
honest before you heat something up it's
not that's bacteria City
I mean that's getting rotten that's not
getting warm you gotta bring you gotta
does that make sense foodborne illnesses
fbis yes whoa It's the temperature shift
that needs to happen rapidly it can't be
a slow grind
through the afternoon that makes sense
Dr Foley I have to concede the point
that's nasty but nasty
can't leave anything in your car today
what about your car
well I mean it's in there for three
hours figure nine to twelve
yeah it's no good that's trash put a
microwave dude
put in the office microwave you're gonna
sit there and tell me and you could tell
me
I'll tell you if there was a slice of
pizza
that I got okay that you got the night
before you take out of the you take out
of the fridge I mean you leave it in the
you leave it in the you leave it out
overnight sometimes no I do of course I
do too but that's not a surging
temperature situation in the hot summer
months it's not a surging temperature I
mean it's getting up to a Honda in there
that's just keeping it what's like a
heat lamp yeah I don't know I don't know
I sometimes think that pizza should
never be refrigerated you should leave
it in the Box in the in the oven which
people do
it's also I'm saying like of course it's
not gonna get to the point where it's
kind of cooked or anything it's just
gonna be warmer than leaving it
on a table does that make sense I don't
know imagine leaving on a table in a hot
room it would depend what it is if it's
a tuna sandwich that's bad
or a sandwich that's bad you have a
leftover so it'd be like I mean like I
don't like a burrito no no I would
assume you know what if it's like a
vodka or a penne vodka or something
alcohol burner at all sear it out I
don't it's not listen it ain't classy I
don't know if I'm necessarily opposed to
it but it's probably not something you
should be making a habit of I would say
you know what I mean yeah it's no good
um all right let's see here this is from
tree guy
more of an am I fancy question okay I
was just thinking about this the other
day too this question exactly huh am I
fancy for cutting out my apples and
spreading peanut butter on them it's a
great all-time snack I think you had me
at fancy at the cutting up of the Apple
I I understand and listen this is how I
rock apples peanut butter or no peanut
butter I love peanut I cut them you do
it seems and I was doing it the other
day and it seemed so childish to me but
also you also waste a lot no I would
argue you waste less you get around that
core well if you have the apple cutter
did you guys have that thing you go hey
yeah I know that I would didn't have
them what were the [__] Kennedys who
has that yeah who had that oh the
mcmullen's rock that heavy really
probably for Apple teenies
they
told your dumb ass it was for your
snacks
it's making sangria later
I got a batch of apple sangria cookies
hey get out of my gimlet cutter
come to think of it I did eat a lot of
garnishes again
man shout out to a plate of garnishes at
an Irish Pub
oh yeah they're all right man
some of them little little pearl onions
um
it seems childish right like you
shouldn't be cutting up food that that's
for children right like you cut up an
Apple for a child because they can't eat
the apple and I'm doing it at 36 with a
receding hairline I'll tell you what
though you ever have an apple with no
skin on it
it's like a piece of candy
I don't know if I could do they Brown
too quick for me
I was skin off [__] oh as a kid oh
yeah there was skin on that I was
throwing it at Denise for sure he was
getting a one back at her
but I'll do I do do the peanut butter I
like the peanut butter apples and peanut
butter is awesome yeah not to get good
so you know what they have now it's wild
you know what they have now half of your
daily a lot of calories what they have
it they have it at patties around the
fall is that uh Marie's you know Marie's
salad dressing sure they do caramel
apple dips in little cups okay
sure the only problem with that is sweet
sky like that yeah get out of the apples
pretty quick and you're just using chips
and pretzels yeah and chips
terrible
I got to Tostitos going a couple of
pretzel rods salty and sweet dude ah
Jesus Christ okay
um I do think uh I think that's very
classy anytime you prepare a snack it's
child and you you put peanut butter on
it I'll give you that the preparedness
of it
does heighten it a little bit Yeah but
that's for children to get children to
eat apples you slice it up because they
can't bite it and then you put peanut
butter on it to get them to eat a piece
of protein that's necessarily not true
cause you ever seen an old schooler
sitting there with like his pocket knife
slicing up an apple that's different
eating pieces very different why is that
different you're using them that's a
slice and bite yeah that's not
pre-arranged slices could you could you
I don't like they eat the skin or
whatever damn you mean your dad did that
made it looks so good if he sat there
with a steak Knife oh my dad would sit
there like he was whittling wood just
[__] slicing it the guys who kill
hobos yeah well in this case it was a
hobo he was in the throat slitter
yeah that's a hobo who kills other hobos
eats his Apple like that are you talking
about the guy from Dennis the Menace
yeah which is Christopher Lloyd yeah
yeah yeah dude when he sits there and
he's cutting that apple and he's got
like warts on him and stuff and he's got
this hairs all straggly boom Man
actually I was about
seven and that guy gave me the
heebie-jeebies and he was making the
beans and the the key to the Handcuff
fell in the beans under the bridge I
remember what
oh man I used to like I don't scare you
more than [__] Bloody Mary I used to
love beans used to baked beans I haven't
had them in years
uh I don't think I've ever even had
baked beans my cousin Kevin makes a
[__] fresh batch we're cousins really
good uh all right let's see here let's
crank out a couple of years
I would I don't think it's fancy I'm
fancy okay I don't know
I say it is it's a healthy nutritious
snack it's loaded with protein that but
you're missing the point it's not the
snack
it's the fact that you're cutting up a
thing that doesn't need to be cut up and
putting something on it that is not an
apple is a nutritious snack
I mean like childing it up you could
just bite a steak but you cut it up you
don't say anything about that you could
just eat a steak you don't have to cut
it up no but everybody eats an apple
that way
they're cut up for children while I'm on
the side I do cut my Apple you you could
make the argument that it can be a
classy accompaniment for like a
charcuterie board
a slice of an apple sliced up Apple with
next to some like cured meats and such
sure yeah but I don't think it's classy
it was like Jiffy peanut butter on it
that ain't classy delish by the way yeah
because if that was the case then orange
slices would be and that's for like
little kids at soccer games yeah man
everyone knows get broken out
so [__] good
fresh [__] Tupperware [__] orange
Lizzies
um turn your lights out all right that
Sugar Rush going through you this one
too this is
sliced apples and peanut butter a little
deeper than we typically do let's be
over our beyond our pay grade uh this is
from Dave Johnson 10 shareholder for two
years now still haven't had a question
read yet my apologies good sir
are polyamorous relationships classy or
trashy the [__] is that
the stud spray paint it's what'd you say
polyamorous polyamorous multiple peoples
more than two people
was a polyamorous relationship your poly
like you would be bisexual
polyamorous is three people in a
relationship I think is the the like how
it is defined T-Bone are you gonna read
on that dude banging two chicks or two
dudes no no no it's never a dude banging
two chicks it's always a chick banging a
bunch of dudes yeah it's typically how
it rolls I mean that is pretty adult I
think it's obviously it's very dope and
there's no judgment on it I would have
it would be execution if it's clean and
everybody's on understandable and go hey
this is how we rock but I feel that
again very real messy very sophisticated
yeah it's polyamory is the practice of
or desire for romantic relationships
with more than one partner at the same
time with informed consent that's
everybody of all Partners involved no it
would be like you have it's not you're
hooking up with two chicks it's you have
two girl relationships and they're all
aware of each other of like hey it's
it's Henry's night it's
I'm not that good looking I can't pull
that off sure I don't you know yeah I
mean not with your nose in the current
state really the dynamic of every
polyamorous relationship is the same
it's one person going I wanna I wanna
have an open relationship and the other
person go in well you think I can't [__]
yeah I don't it's not my cup of tea it's
not my world I don't know if I really
know anybody I guess none of those
people are slicing their apples
I just seems like it would be very
yeah it seems it can be done very
messily but if everybody's on the same
page it all makes sense I get it yeah I
like that it seems very adult very
sophisticated yes it can be like it
seems like you're in charge of your
emotions a little bit which I would feel
I would not you know what are you doing
it's 2023. oh no of course I'm just
breaking it like in the way I see it of
like
that would be very mature to me which I
tend to be less trashy yeah you know
what I mean like if something if it's
like hey the three of us have figured
this thing out and this is how we do it
and it's okay it's been working for a
year ago they did a movie like that they
did that Oliver Stone movie it seems
was the two dudes in Blake Lively they
got caught up in some kind of drug deal
oh right what was that they were hot
though everybody
beach house or something yeah Lively
they were both like ex-navy SEALS or
something like that they took on a drug
lord they did something they were hot
everybody involved in that was A-Okay
I'm gonna die it was the kid it was the
guy that played Gambit in uh in uh X-Men
uh uh Blake Lively
movie drugs sexy
hot dudes yeah like oh they go out on a
couch remember being like what though
and then the other dude like Savages
yeah I think it was Savages yeah yeah I
literally I literally searched Blake
Lively movie drug sex yeah there you go
one Dude Looks Like That Austin but you
can get a copy that sentiment kids
gorgeous kid that played Elvis I've I've
had the opportunity to you know hook up
with people in open relationships in the
past and I've always steered clear of it
that's how you get killed man that's how
you get killed that's how you get shot
some guy comes home from work you said I
said it's dudes I said no Tuesdays next
thing you know you're shot no thank you
I just don't like the idea of someone
coming back and then and then another
guy being like how was the date and then
now my sexual prowess is getting
reviewed by some Barista on a couch yeah
I'm like he bones uncircumcised gross
really [__] beard neck beard coder oh
cause you know they're talking about it
exactly that's the turn on though yeah
I like it
caught up in your little sex web
um this one's from Ethan uh have you
ever blown your nose into anything else
other than a tissue or a napkin like in
the middle exclusively you reach over
stuffed up and grab the nearest shirt
from the floor absofucking lutely ain't
nothing wrong with it that happens from
time to time what are you gonna do a
towel a sock a sock you suck yeah that's
what's on your nose dude that's
athlete's nose
let me pee on it get over here
yeah socks are no good yeah and I'll
tell you this in a hotel
Obama we're on the road and I'm alone
I'll [__] blow my nose right in that
bed sheet you're [__] gross dude
if I'm jammed up
yeah meaning I don't want to get out of
bed it's jammed up yeah sure most of
your behavior is stemmed from
gluttony and laziness I was gonna say uh
being jammed up I was gonna say
something a little harsher I guess
um all right let's see let's do one more
here
uh
uh we're gonna double up for Mr uh
Canelo all right
um is it garbage to learn to drive in a
graveyard
my mom would teach us there because
there's no traffic and a lot of turns
it makes sense it does too I I get it I
never thought of that I got taught in a
parking lot
I been on Cathcart Road where I stormed
out of the car my dad was like what the
[__] yeah kind of a big fight and I
started walking away
my dad taught me for two seconds God I
was a [__] [__]
what he should have beat the [__] out of
me screaming at people trying to help
you yeah
I [__] got it God
slam the door blow the bridge and when
you out for him help God I remember
looking back and looking through the the
back window and just seeing him sitting
there in the passenger seat like what
the [__]
[__] Saturday afternoon trying to
show his fat dumb kid out of Drive
doesn't appreciate it sure I love you
Pop
God damn it yeah
um no I gotta break it green lights
[Laughter]
oh man that one stings yeah
um I learned in the back of my dad's
office he had like a warehouse what are
you gonna say the back seat of the car
that wasn't driving son that car was
stick shift
I remember him being like yeah if you
let off the break it's gonna go
like he said that through the window and
I was driving his Jeep Cherokee okay
like I was in there I started it
I was like 14 probably
and he was like if you let go of the
break you're gonna start going that was
my first time I was like oh this thing's
just gonna move on its own
I theoretically learned how to drive on
a on a lawn mower
you would drive that but like you know a
car car
and I would just I would just do loops
in the back of his office while he was
working by the way I wanted to point
something out about uh Mr tonello there
he referred to it as a graveyard and not
a cemetery yeah
it's a bunch of unmarked [__] Graves
that's the graveyard's bad a cemetery is
nice [__] Potter's field yeah it's
peaceful it's respectful the graveyard
is where the ghost lives
yeah but we gotta wrap her up again oh
man what a fun one gang we love you to
death as you know the tickets are on
sale for the stay trashy tour yes sir
scoop them up it's the first leg of the
tour we're gonna be adding a bunch of
more dates it's gonna be a fun time
we're gonna be rocking and rolling all
the way through the year we can't wait
to see you guys we love you and we'll
see you next week